these are the last few images taken by a
NASA spacecraft seconds before it's
smashed into a 5 million tonne asteroid
[Applause]
you can tell by the celebrations back on
Earth the crash was no accident
the dart mission is the first test of a
potential planetary defense system to
deflect dangerous asteroids from our
home planet
NASA chose their target carefully a
small asteroid orbiting another seven
million miles from Earth
Dart approached the asteroid pair Didi
moss and dimorphos at nearly 15 000
miles an hour it aimed for head-on
collision with a 160 meter wide
dimorphos cameras on a buddy satellite
called leecher Cube recorded the impact
and The Cloud of debris The Hope is the
crash will slow dimorphoses orbit but it
will take months of observations to
prove it has worked
immediately they'll be looking at how
much debris is ejected from the asteroid
after impact the more stuff we come out
the more we move and the campaign to
understand that and how much we've
really uh you know how much we've moved
it will happen over the next year and
there's actually telescopes all across
the globe that are going to be looking
at uh dinamos and dimorphous and trying
to understand how much we've changed uh
over the next year if an asteroid the
size of dimorphos were to hit Earth it
could destroy a city it's not the size
that this you know going to end life on
the planet but it's large enough that it
could cause a significant problem
if one that size was ever discovered
coming towards Earth and so being able
to do something about that seems like a
very sensible technology to have no
known asteroid large and 140 meters is
expected to collide with Earth in The
Next Century but only 40 percent of the
smaller asteroids have been found
so if dark proves to have been a success
more campaigns to study and track space
rocks will be needed to spot danger
early enough to leave enough time to
knock it safely out of the way
Tom Clark Sky News